There are a lot of things in life worth caring
about.
Things we consider important and meaningful.
Things that affect the narrative of our lives.
But beneath all the things that construct
our narratives, the one thing a human should
take most seriously in life, is not taking
life too seriously.
Life is simply too complicated.
It is too far out of our comprehension to
claim it as something that we can take as
seriously as many of us often do.
We could very well be characters in some intricate
simulation.
We could very well be the most intelligent
life forms in the universe, prospective gods
to those that reside beneath us.
We could very well be living a reality that
is merely a projection of each of our own
individual consciousness, with no root in
objective truth.
Or we could be nothing more than a collectively
evolving bacteria, destine to feed off the
planets of the universe, with zero purpose
or benefit to anything outside of our selves.
Some possibilities regarding our existence
bare a bleak outlook for humanity.
Others suggest promising idealistic ones.
Either way, we do not know and we may never
know.
Therefore, we must not let trivial inconveniences
and troubles affect us too much in life.
Because what a shame it would be to live a
life filled with stress, worry, and concern
for things that end up not even being real
or important.
Things we could have chosen to ignore.
Would it not be the safer bet to work towards
enjoying life, floating with the tides, adapting
to new situations, and not letting things
ruin our ability to embrace life’s profound
mystery?
It is important that we care about the things
that we deem relevant and meaningful in life,
but it is equally important to live with the
acknowledgement that it could all just be
illusory.
Nothing more than a crazy dream or trip of
the mind, with no real relevance or stake
in anything beyond the mere experience of
it.
And the best way to embrace this and maximize
the experience is to try our best to be lighthearted
and fluid.
To laugh at our problems so we can cry tears
of joy over life’s wonder.